[APPLAUSE]
NOVA REN SUMA: Thank you so
much for that great intro,
[? Sunny. ?] So I'm
Nova, and I am here
to talk about "The Walls
Around Us," which just came out
this spring from Algonquin.
And this is a young
adult novel, a YA novel.
And I've said this before
outside of this room,
but I'll say this here.
I write stories about
teenagers, most specifically,
teenage girls, but that
doesn't necessarily
mean that my books
are for teenagers.
My books are for anyone who
is interested in that moment
in time, that point of being,
that urgent, frightening,
exciting point of
being a teenager,
that point when everything
seems important, and dire,
and it seems like your whole
life is about to start,
although, life has
already started,
and that exciting point in
life is what I write about.
And that's what found its way
into "The Walls Around Us."
But what also found its way
was some supernatural elements
and some ghosts.
So when I first started thinking
of what I wanted to write next,
as this is my fourth
book, I was thinking,
I really want to
write a ghost story.
And I didn't know where
to start with that.
I just knew somehow, I
want to write something
that feels like a classic
ghost story somehow,
but is also really
steeped in the real world.
And my inspirations--
a direct inspiration
would be Shirley
Jackson, who I love.
"We Have Always
Lived in the Castle"
is a favorite book of
mine, and of course,
"The Haunting of Hill House,"
which is really chilling
and gave me a nightmare.
So that's the
direct inspiration,
and also, David Lynch films.
I'm a huge "Twin Peaks" fan.
And what I love is that everyday
place, that ordinary world,
or ordinary town.
And then there's some
strange little oddity,
something other, something odd.
And I always like to play
with that in my writing.
So I was thinking about I want
to write something surreal.
I want to write
something with ghosts.
And I thought, I need a place.
I need a solid place
to set this story.
Good ghost stories have a
really strong sense of place.
And what came to me,
around the same time,
I was also watching a lot
of-- I don't even know why
at the time, watching a lot of
documentaries about prisons,
reading a lot about
people incarcerated.
It was just an interest
of mine, and something
that I was just collecting, and
I didn't necessarily know why.
And then I thought, I can set
this ghost story in a prison.
And then, of course, because
I write about teenagers,
it could be a juvenile
detention center.
And of course, because I
write about teenage girls.
Most specifically, it could be
an all girls juvenile detention
center.
So I created this imaginary
juvenile detention center
far up in upstate New York.
As Sunny said, I'm
from the Hudson Valley,
but this is a little farther
north than where I grew up.
I imagined it to be on
the top of a tall hill,
with grey stone walls, and
three lines of fencing,
and barbed wire.
And I imagine that originally,
it was a prison for adult men,
and that it was
converted and renovated
to house teenage girls who had
committed violent crimes, very
serious crimes.
So I had my place.
I had this sense of
where the story would be.
And yet, for me, as a writer,
a place is not enough.
What I need is a character.
I need a person.
I need a voice.
So I needed to find my voice.
And that's really how
I start a story is
to find how the person
telling the story
is going to let
us into her world.
I often write in first person.
So I was coming up with
this character named Amber.
She has been incarcerated in
the aurora hills secure juvenile
detention center since
she was 14 years old.
She was convicted
of manslaughter
for killing her stepfather.
And I knew that this
would be my character,
but I didn't know
how she would speak.
It's so important to
know how she speaks.
And so I began to write
strangely in second person,
meaning she's saying
we, instead of I.
And then I realized that it
wasn't a true second person
voice.
It was more that
my character was
telling everyone else's
stories, in addition to her own.
She was seeing everyone
else around her.
She's the person sitting at
the table, at the corner,
being very quiet, listening
to everyone else talk,
and collecting their stories.
And that's the kind
of narrator that she
exposed herself to be when
I was trying to invent her.
So around the time that I'm
inventing, thinking of Amber,
and thinking of this story
that I knew I wanted to write,
this ghost story
in this prison, I
got a writing residency,
an artist residency
at the Millay Colony
in upstate New York,
in Austerlitz, New York.
And the Millay Colony
is on Edna St. Vincent
Millay, the poet's property.
And there's actually
the colony area,
and then across the street is
Steepletop, Edna St. Vincent
Millay's house.
Her grave site is
on the property.
There's just this
refuge away from things.
And it houses-- you can
get a month long residency,
and it's for
writers, and artists
of all disciplines, composers.
So I had this residency for
November, in November, I think,
of 2012.
And all I knew going
up there is that I
wanted to write this book.
And I had this character,
but I didn't have any pages.
I didn't have any start to it.
It was just this
kernel in my head.
And I had this month
long period to write it
at the Millay colony.
And when you get an artist
residency like this,
there's no one looking
over your shoulder.
There's no one at
the end of the week,
like how many pages
did you write,
or at the end of your
stay, asking even
to see what you've done.
No one is checking
up on you, which
is a wonderful sense of
freedom, that you can
use the time however you want.
But at the same time,
there's that pressure
that you give yourself.
I was going away from
home for four weeks
to produce something,
and so my goal
was I'm going to write so much.
I'm going to make so much
progress in this book.
I had a really high
standard for myself
on what I wanted to produce.
But when I got there,
things don't always
work out as you hope, and
creativity is hard to rein in.
And I kept writing, trying
to write in Amber's voice,
and I kept getting stuck, and
I kept writing pages I thought
were awful.
I kept throwing them
out, just feeling really,
this is not right.
I couldn't find the
way into the story.
So my time there became I
would sit down at my desk
and try and write
in the morning,
and just be really focused.
And I would write awful
things that I hated
that were not worth keeping.
I had to read for a
little bit, I'd try again.
And then at the end of the
day, this was in November.
So before sunset,
before dinner, I
would take a walk
outside in the property,
and just waring with myself,
and angry with myself,
like you're not
getting anywhere.
What's going on?
So there was this trail on the
Millay Colony property called
the Poetry Trail.
And along the path,
in through the woods,
are these poems, or
excerpts of poems
by Edna St. Vincent Millay, just
little signposts on the side.
And I would walk along and
read these poems every day,
just absorbing them
again and again.
And I should say, this is
upstate New York, in the fall,
during hunting season.
So the artists were
told, if we want
to go walking alone,
wear bright colors.
So I'd be walking
the poetry trail
with this bright orange
vest on over my sweater,
watching the sunset
through trees.
No one else was ever on
the trail when I was on it.
And I would walk all
the way down to the end,
starting off feeling really
bad about my progress
during the day, but
stopped thinking about it.
And just sometimes, ideas come
when you're not forcing them.
Just kept walking, and Edna
St. Vincent Millay's grave
is at the end of this trail,
as well as her mother's grave.
And I would just sit there,
and think for awhile,
and then go back in, and that
would be the end of the day,
and then we'd have dinner.
And toward the end
of my residency,
something clicked,
and I realized that I
had found this voice for Amber.
I had a phrase.
All I knew is that it would
start with "We went wild."
I had three words.
And that could be
anything in this story.
I knew it would set
in a detention center.
So I was thinking,
this could be a riot.
This could be, I don't know.
What crazy thing is happening
in which these girls go wild
inside the walls of this
juvenile detention center.
So I started writing,
and I got a sentence.
I got a paragraph,
and that's all I got.
I basically spent a month
writing one paragraph,
and this is writing every
day, trying very hard.
But this one paragraph
led me into this story.
This was the voice
that I was looking for.
This was the entryway
into this world.
This was everything I needed.
And in fact, as you'll
hear, because I'm
going to read from it, and
you'll hear this paragraph,
the paragraph that I wrote
there, in the first draft,
ended up being almost exactly
the same in the final book
after all the edits it went
through, and revisions,
and working with my editor.
I think there were maybe two
word changes or something.
But it ended up being the exact
right way to tell this story,
after all that searching.
And even though I
went home thinking,
I went away for a month, and
here, I have one paragraph,
it really was the right
thing for this book.
Sometimes, things happen
very, very slowly.
And sometimes, it takes
you an entire month
of writing every day to
come up with one paragraph.
So I thought that I would
read from the first chapter.
And you'll get a sense
of Amber's voice,
and you'll also
hear the paragraph.
But also, what happens after
the paragraph, where it led me.
And you'll recognize
the three words.
We went wild.
We went wild that hot night.
We howled, we
raged, we screamed.
We were girls, some of us
14 and 15, some 16, 17.
But when the locks came undone,
the doors of our cells gaping
open, and no one to
shove us back in,
we made the noise of
savage animals, of men.
We flooded the corridors,
crowding together,
and the clammy, cooped up dark.
We abandoned our
assigned colors.
Green for most of us, yellow
for those of us in segregation,
traffic cone orange for anyone
unlucky enough to be new.
We left behind our
jumpsuit skins.
We showed off our
angry, wobbly tattoos.
When outside, the
thunder crashed,
we overtook A wing and B wing.
When lightning flashed,
we mobbed C wing.
We even took our
chances in D wing,
which held suicide
watch and solitary.
We were gasoline,
rushing for a lit match.
We were bared
teeth, balled fists,
a stampede of slick feet.
We went wild, like anyone would.
We lost our fool heads.
Just try to understand.
After the crimes that
had put us inside,
after all the hideous things we
were accused of and convicted
of, the things some of us
had done without apology,
and some of us had sworn
we were innocent of doing,
sworn on our mothers
if we have mothers,
sworn our pets if we ever had
a puppy dog or a scrawny cat,
sworn on our own measly
lives, if we had nobody--
after all that time behind bars,
on this night, we were free.
We were free.
Some of us found
that terrifying.
On this night, the first
Saturday of that now
infamous August,
there were 41 girl's
locked up in the Aurora Hills
Secure Juvenile Detention
Center in the far northern
reaches of the state, which
meant we were one
shy of full capacity.
We weren't yet 42.
To our surprise, to
our wide-eyed delight,
the cells of B wing and C wing,
of A wing, and even D wing,
had come open.
And there, we stood, a
thunder of thudding hearts
in the darkness.
We stood outside or cages.
We stood outside.
We looked to the guard stations.
They were unmanned.
We looked to the sliding gates
at the end of our corridors.
They were wide open.
We looked to the flood lights
wringing the high ceiling.
The bulbs had gone dim.
We looked, or we tried to look.
It was the way our bodies
pulled through the window slits
and into the storm
pounding outside,
all across the compound.
If only we could see just pass
the triple fenced perimeter,
over and beyond the
coils of barbed wire,
past the guard's tower,
past the steep road
that plunge downhill to the
tall iron gate at the bottom.
We remembered from when
the blue painted short bus
from the county jail
had carried us up here.
We remembered we weren't so
far from the public road.
That was when it hit
us how little time we
were sure to have before
the corrections officers
returned to their posts.
Maybe we should have
been sensible about
our sudden freedom, cautious.
We weren't.
We didn't stop to question
the open locks-- not then.
We didn't pause to wonder why
the emergency lights hadn't
blinked on, why the
alarms didn't blare.
We didn't think either
about the COs who
were supposed to
be on night duty,
where they could have gone,
why their booths were empty,
their chairs bare.
We scattered.
We spread out.
We pushed through
barriers that were always
locked to us before.
We ran.
The night burst open, the way
a good riot tends to, when
it takes over the
yard, and no one
knows who started what or cares.
The shouts and screams,
the whops and wales.
41 of the worst female juvenile
offenders in the state set
lose without warning, or reason,
or armed guard to take us down.
It was beautiful,
and it was powerful,
like lightning in our hands.
Some of us weren't
thinking and only wanted
to kick in the glass
fronts of the vending
machines in the
canteen for snacks,
or pillage pills from
the clinic to get a fix.
Some of us wanted to pound a
face in and jump someone, jump
anyone.
It didn't matter who.
A couple of us simply
wanted to slip out back
under the murky cloud
covering and shoot some hoops
in the rain.
Then there were
those of us, the ones
with brains who took a
breath and considered,
because with no COs
coming at us with clubs
out, no alarms bleeding or
intercoms crackling commands
to herd us back to
our cells, the night
really was ours for the first
time in days, weeks, months,
years.
And what's a girl to do with
her first free night in years?
The most violent among
us, the daddy killers,
the slitters of stranger's
throats, the point
blank shooters of pleading
gas station attendants
would later admit to
finding a sense of peace
in the plush darkness,
a kind of justice
not offered by the
juvenile courts.
Sure, some of us knew we
didn't deserve this reprieve.
Not one of us was
truly innocent,
not when we were made to
stand in the light, our bits,
and cavities, and
cavity fillings exposed.
When we faced this
truth inside ourselves,
it somehow felt more
ugly than the day
we witnessed the judge say,
guilty and heard the courtroom
cheer.
That was why a few
of us hung back,
didn't leave ourselves where we
kept our drawings and our love
letters, where we
stewed our one good comb
and stashed all
our Reese's Peanut
Butter cups, which were
like gold doubloons
up in Aurora Hills, since we
didn't have access to cash.
Some of us stayed
put in the place
we knew, because
what was out there?
Who would keep us
safe on the outside?
Where really would a girl
from a Aurora Hills, who
disappointed her family and
scared off English teachers,
and social workers,
and public defenders,
and anyone who
tried to help her,
a girl who terrorized
her neighborhood,
who was as good as
garbage, she'd been told,
who was probably
best left forgotten,
she'd read this in
letters from home.
Where was a girl
like that to go?
A lot of us did try to run,
even if it was only habit.
Some of us had been
running all our lives.
We ran, because we could,
and because we couldn't not.
We ran for our lives.
We still thought they
were worth running for.
Most of us didn't get far.
We got distracted,
overexcited, overcome.
A couple of us came
to a stop somewhere
in one of the hallways
outsider designated wing,
and sank to the cracked and
pitted floor in gratitude,
as if we'd been acquitted
of all our crimes,
our records expunged.
This felt like
everything we dared
let ourselves dream, when the
taunting fantasy slipped in
between the bars.
Wishes for fast getaway
cars or Rapunzel
ropes to climb out the
narrow window openings, pleas
for forgiveness, for vengeance,
for glittery new lives
on some far off riviera,
where we'd never again have
to face hate, or law, or pain.
It was happening to us.
We never did believe it
could happen to kids like us.
Some of us cried.
There we were, set loose
on the defenseless night,
instantly wanting
everything we could imagine,
to thumb a ride at
the nearest freeway,
to call an old
boyfriend and get laid,
to have a never ending
breadstick feast at The Olive
Garden, to sleep under fluffy
covers, and a large, soft bed.
That August marked my third
summer at Aurora Hills.
I've been locked up
here since I was 14.
Manslaughter, I played innocent.
I stuffed myself into a skirt
and sheer hose for trial.
My mother turned her face
away when I was found guilty
and hasn't look my way since.
But it's not my arrival I
find myself thinking about,
now that we have so much
time to sit here, thinking.
It's not the judge's ruling,
and the deafening years
of my sentence, and
how I landed here
because not one person believed
me when I said I didn't do it.
I let go of all that
a long time ago.
It's this one night that
I keep coming back to,
that first Saturday in
August, when the locks
couldn't hold us, that
brief gift of freedom
we'd take to our graves.
I get hung up on it
sometimes, and what if things
had gone another way if
I'd made it past the gates
and gotten out, if I'd run.
Maybe I would have made it
over the three sets of fencing
and down the hill to
the free patch of road,
and my part in this
story would be over.
Maybe all that was about to
come tumbling at us after this,
someone else would have
to bear witness to.
Someone else would have
to do the remembering,
because that was the
night we went wild.
I remember how we
fought, and we cried,
and we hid, and we flung
ourselves through windows,
and we pumped our
legs with everything
we had, and we went running
as far as we could make it,
which wasn't far.
On that night, we
felt emotions we
haven't had a taste of for 6
months, 12 months, 11 and 1/2
weeks, 909 days.
We were alive.
I remember it that way.
We were still alive,
and we couldn't
make heads or tails
of the darkness,
so we couldn't see how
close we were to the end.
So that's the first chapter
of "The Walls Around Us,"
and that's Amber speaking and
bringing us into the story.
But you got a hint
in the introduction
that this book has been
called-- and I admit,
I did not come up with this.
I am not a marketing genius--
"Orange is the New Black"
meets "Black Swan," or "Orange
is the New Black Swan."
And so you might be
wondering-- right.
And whoever came up with
that hashtag, thank you.
So "Orange is the
New Black Swan."
So you must be wondering,
where is the "Black Swan"
reference in this?
So half of the story takes
place inside the prison walls
at Aurora Hills, but the
other half of the story
takes place outside.
And the narrator for
that half of the story
is an 18-year-old
ballerina named
Violet, who is about to
head off to New York City
to live the life of her dreams.
Everything is coming true that
she wanted and worked for.
And yet, she is
holding onto a very
tangled, complicated,
awful secret.
And her best friend, who
used to be a dancer with her
at the ballet school
where she studied,
ended up being
convicted of murder
and sent away to the Aurora
Hills Secure Juvenile Detention
Center, where she was
the cell mate of Amber.
So that's how the two stories
converge and are connected.
And Violet's story actually
takes place two years later.
And there was a distance.
She's about to leave town.
And I'm just going to read you
a little bit from her voice
to give you a sense
of the Violet section.
This is not a whole chapter.
So what's happening
right now is Violet
is standing backstage,
about to perform
for the last time for her town's
ballet recital, the summer
recital.
And she's about
to perform a solo.
And she's, of course,
thinking of her former best
friend, Orianna,
who she calls Ori,
and thinking how Ori
was a better dancer
and if she had been here,
how different it would be.
And she's also
thinking about how glad
she is to get out of here.
For Ori, dancing came naturally,
without a nervous stomach
or worries if she'd
forget the steps.
She danced like
it was meant to be
in a way that
couldn't be copied,
no matter how carefully
I watched her move,
mirroring my body
after hers, and trying
to get my limbs to loosen
up, and act more free.
She had this vivid spark
of life in her wanting out,
and you could see it clear,
when she took the floor.
I never witnessed
anyone move like that.
I guess I won't ever again.
If Ori and I were
dancing a duet tonight,
she for sure would've
been better than me.
The audience would
have basked in her,
loved her, followed her
light across the stage.
My light would have
been background.
That's the truth,
or it could've been.
It's no longer
the truth anymore.
I let the curtain drop.
I'm on.
I hear my cue.
I take my first steps
out onto the stage.
And next, I hear
her voice, which
she would have said to
me, had she been here,
breathe, V. Go be amazing.
Go show them.
Let them all see.
She used to say things like
that to me all the time.
I'm at my mark.
The darkness lifts, and
my body lifts with it.
And I'm tall now,
as tall as Ori,
because she had only a
couple of inches on me.
Taller even, because maybe
since she's been gone, I grew.
I'm balanced on point, on
one leg, without a tremor,
without sway.
The spot of light circles me,
and I'm growing warm inside it.
I wonder how I look from
out there in the audience
to those strangers in the seats
who know me this way only, who
have no idea.
I don't need a
mirror to tell me.
I look like I belong up here.
I've got new Grishkos on,
broken in this morning
by massaging the shank
and slamming the hard cast
of the box into a door.
My mother sewed the ribbons
on with the tiniest stitches.
No one could ever
hope to see them.
My hair is pin slick
with shine to my head,
and the tutu is a rigid
ring around my middle,
not as flimsy as it might seem.
I'm entirely in white.
I wanted it that color.
I asked for it.
The audience holds
its breath for me.
Ori's not the one up here.
I am.
The audience eyes my
bent and poised leg,
my arms molded in
a graceful line
over my head, my lifted
and lengthened spine.
All my weight is
on a single toe.
I hold.
At least a dozen people watching
from the wings want me to fall,
and I'm not falling.
Now comes the building
crescendo of music,
every little
increment of movement
from my body studied
in mirrored reflection,
coached and
corrected into place.
It may not be as free form
as Ori would have done it,
but it's impressive,
because I'm so precise.
I make no mistakes,
not a single one.
People in the audience can't
hear the clomp of the brand
new shoes as I touch weight
to ground between each whip
fast pirouette.
Or if they do hear,
if they're seated
close enough to the stage
to hear, they ignore it.
They wanted our secret.
They want me to win.
But there's another secret.
Inside, past the tool, and the
skin tight stretch of fabric
going three layers deep, I've
got things I can't talk about,
things Ori knew
and only Ori knew.
If you peel away the first
layer, and the second layer,
and the third layer,
underneath would
be something ugly, something
broken-- eyes clawed out,
and blood still clinging to
her neck, her arms, her face.
Sometimes, I think I still
have the blood on my face.
There's this
thumping, and it's not
my pristine pair of point
shoes touching floor
for the first night
in their short lives.
It's what's going on in my head.
It's a stampede.
It may look like I'm dancing,
but I'm somewhere else.
I'm out there,
behind the dumpster,
in the tunnel of trees, and I'm
screaming and flinging my arms,
and dirt is
everywhere, and rocks,
and twigs, and
leaves, and blackness,
the whole world's
getting knocked out
like a set of teeth.
I'm out there, even now,
as much as I'm in here.
Before I know it, I reach
the end of the choreography.
I can barely keep it together.
But still, I finish my
solo with a flourish,
poised on one rock solid leg.
Silence.
They say nothing, do nothing.
I can hear them all breathe.
Then it happens.
The seats creak, and shift,
and people rise to their feet.
I've given them everything.
I've given them
too much this time.
And then I realize.
It takes me a moment to realize.
These people really
have no idea, do they?
I showed them, and
they couldn't see.
They start cheering for me.
These people-- family,
friends, strangers,
all those innocent strangers,
they stand on their feet
for me, and their
hands smack and smack
with increasing violence,
and they shower me with noise
like they wish I never had to
leave this town or the stage.
They're praising me.
They're showing me how much
they love me and have always
loved me, no matter what.
Look how blind they are.
They're giving me a standing O.
So that's Violet, the
other voice in the story.
And so much of the writing
of this book, for me,
was about exploring
guilt, and innocence,
and who really is guilty,
and who really is innocent,
and what happens when one
is mistaken for the other.
So that is Introduction
to the book.
And I think we'll have a
little bit of discussion,
and then they'll
open for questions,
if anyone has questions.
AUDIENCE: So one
thing that struck
me is just the voices
for Violet and Amber
are so very different.
What did you have
to do to yourself
to get into each of
the other girl's heads?
NOVA REN SUMA: It's really hard
writing a first person voice
trying to sound like someone.
And then you inhabit it so much
that then everything you write
sounds like this person.
So it's hard when
you're switching
between two different voices.
So for me, I tend to
write my books in order.
So this is a problem when
you're switching chapters.
In this book, it's
more like sections,
instead of alternating chapters.
But even so, I would
be so into Amber.
And then I would move
into writing Violet,
and some of the
Amber would slip in.
So I ended up having to separate
the book into two pieces
and write just the Amber
story straight through
and write just the Violet
story straight through.
And I actually
gave myself rules.
That always helps when I'm
trying to write something.
It's down to the specifics
of this character
is not allowed to use
adverbs, and this character
is allowed to have semicolons
and em dashes, and just down
to the sentence level.
This character can have
more casual language.
This character can have flighty
diversions in her thinking,
and get caught up in her head.
And I had a list on
the wall of the things
Amber was allowed to do
and the things Violet
was allowed to do.
And even down to
editing a later draft,
I realized that
sometimes, I would slip,
so I would-- no em dash!
And I would have to switch it.
But that helped,
and also, just being
in the voice of that character
and reading it straight
through-- and I know
a lot of writers
do this-- [? along ?]
as playlists.
I had very specific songs
that went with each character,
and sometimes,
even each chapter.
So when I was
working on a chapter,
even down to revising
it, in the third draft,
I would put on the song
that went with that chapter
to remind myself of the
feeling of writing it
and remind myself
of Amber or Violet.
AUDIENCE: So can give us a
sample playlist for each girl?
NOVA REN SUMA: I know I
should put that online.
I could say that Amber's
songs were more dreamy.
Her voice is more
poetic and more lyrical,
and so her songs were
slower and dreamier,
and Violet's songs were angry.
Angry music would
go with Violet.
And it didn't have to be
anything that she necessarily
would listen to.
It would just be something
that had that power of punch
in the lyrics, or the
song, or just something
to make me mad
when I was writing,
because I felt like
that anger was needed
when I was writing her voice.
But I should put up
a playlist of the two
different characters.
It might be interesting.
AUDIENCE: I think so.
Does that make you a
method writer then?
NOVA REN SUMA: [LAUGHING]
A method writer.
Maybe.
I think part of it, when you're
writing first person voice,
you're really trying
to inhabit a person.
You're really trying to see
the world through that voice.
Bad first person is just
you're writing, "I,"
and it could be "she."
It could just be easily
changed, and you're not
feeling it from that character.
In that case, don't even bother.
Just use third
person, is my opinion.
If you're using first
person in the right way,
you're saying everything the
way this person would say it.
You're noticing
things in the room
that that person
would notice, and only
that person would notice.
And the feeling of
being who that person is
comes through in how her
side of the story is told.
So you have to really
get close to a character.
And maybe that is
method writing.
That's funny.
AUDIENCE: And I was
actually hoping for a story
where you, yourself, launched
yourself into prison.
NOVA REN SUMA: [LAUGHING] No.
I didn't do that.
But one thing I would do
when writing this book
specifically was I live in a
small apartment in Manhattan,
and I have a writing
space where I go to,
which is a loft space, The
Writer's Room in Manhattan,
which is wonderful, where I
rent access and have access
to a desk.
But there are people around.
Sometimes, I write in cafes,
but there are people around.
And this book could
get really intense,
and this book could get
really dark and emotional.
And I couldn't be
around all the people.
So I made-- in our bedroom,
in our tiny bedroom,
a tent over my desk, and it
was covering the window too.
It must've been awful, just this
whole tent area in the corner.
So if I went into my
desk, I could see nothing,
and I was just covered
by this dark tent.
And actually, one of
the most intense scenes,
a murder scene that
happens in this book
was written in the tent.
And I had to leave the tent up
when I was revising the book,
because I needed access to that
space, that contained space,
where it was just
me and the story.
I couldn't even see anything.
There were no
lights in the tent.
It was just dark, and
then my computer screen.
And then I would go
in there to revise
this really intense scene.
AUDIENCE: How did you come up
with all the other inmates?
Like all the other girls,
their personalities,
and the different crimes?
It almost reads a
little bit like it's
from "Chicago," except there's
no singing and dancing.
NOVA REN SUMA: I love "Chicago."
Thank you.
I thought of all the
possible crimes, many of them
violent, that would
lead to a girl
to be locked up in this
place, and her circumstances,
and what privileges
she didn't have,
or what would lead
her to be left here.
And so many of the
girls, it's like they are
considered to have no future.
And even if their
sentences end, what
happens to them after, when
you've spent all this time
incarcerated in this place?
And so I thought of all
the possible crimes.
And then I thought of the girl
who might have committed this
crime or was accused
of it and didn't.
There's a point in
here where it says,
they all say they're innocent.
Some of them are innocent.
Some of them aren't innocent.
And so it was fun and
interesting to create
these girls who had had
these terrible mistakes
and ended up here.
And there are quite
a few of them.
And I feel like I could
have gone and written
whole sections, whole chapters
about them and their stories.
I could've kept going.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
is your fourth novel,
and it falls on the heels
of [? Danny ?] [INAUDIBLE]--
NOVA REN SUMA: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: --imaginary
girls and some [INAUDIBLE].
NOVA REN SUMA: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: So if I were
just being very literal,
looking at just the titles,
this seems a common theme,
is disappearing.
NOVA REN SUMA: That's
very astute, yeah.
And actually, the
book I'm writing now
has a little bit of
that theme, as well.
I think that's something that
I've always written about,
as a girl.
And I think when I was
younger, because I've always
written-- I've always
wanted to be a writer.
And I think for me, it was
a way to talk to people.
It was a way to speak.
I was so incredibly
shy when I was young.
I was that kid in class
who couldn't speak.
I was called on in class, and I
would turn bright red, and just
very uncomfortable.
It's amazing that
I'm standing up here
in front of this room talking.
I would never have seen myself
doing something like that.
And I think the writing
is the way I found
myself able to communicate.
And a lot of it was
I want to disappear.
I want to be invisible.
And I think that theme,
those were stories
that I wrote when I was younger.
But that theme has
translated to all of my books
in interesting ways, different
ways of attacking it,
different ways of finding
myself speaking about that.
So that's great that
you brought that up.
AUDIENCE: So how does that theme
come to play [INAUDIBLE] this,
because if you just go by the
title, again, solely the title,
it seems like it's
the most concrete.
They can't get out
to the [INAUDIBLE].
NOVA REN SUMA: Yeah.
"The Walls Around Us."
Really, the way of what happens
to a teenager, a young kid when
they commit a crime like this,
and basically, their whole life
changes.
They're sent away to a juvenile
detention center to do time.
And it's almost like
their entire old life
has disappeared.
Who they were has disappeared.
And a lot of the thought
of these prisoners as
what is my life when I get out?
What is my life
after I do my time?
Is this mark ever-- is this
still on me for forever?
So there's a lot of that.
And then there's also
sometimes in my writing,
I like to play with magical
realism and fantastical things.
And the disappearing
can be quite literal.
People actually can disappear
and have in my books.
I won't give anymore away.
AUDIENCE: Is there an author
whose career or body of work
you'd like yours to
look like [INAUDIBLE]?
NOVA REN SUMA: Oh!
I'm just going to be
honest and say this
even though she's a friend.
I greatly admire the
[INAUDIBLE] author, Libba Bray.
And what I admire about Libba
is she's so incredibly talented
with the range of her work.
So she has written
historical fantasy.
Her latest series,
"The Diviners,"
is 1920s New York, with
the occult, and politics,
and sweeping epic stories,
as well as satire,
and funny things,
and first person
beautiful voice-y things.
And I look at her, and I think,
if only I could find a way
to have that kind of
range as a writer,
and to be able to explore
everything so honestly,
where it still feels like me.
In every book, that's different.
And I admire that so much.
But I also admire how
she carries herself
in this industry, how helpful
she is to fellow writers,
and how wonderful she is with
her fans, and how open she is.
And so I very much
think I would love
to find a way to build a
career like Libba's one day
and to have published the kind
of books that she publishes.
AUDIENCE: I think yours is
off to more than a good start.
Just going back to
"The Walls Around Us,"
was there a reason why you
chose Stravinsky's "Firebird"
as the ballet?
NOVA REN SUMA: Yes.
So in the story,
Violet is, in the past,
they were performing the
"Firebird" as the summer
showcase ballet.
And Ori, her best
friend, was cast
in the important starring
role of the firebird, which
was the best role that Violet
wanted, and she didn't get.
So for me, sometimes, this
book, I will tell you,
is complete fiction.
I was never in a juvenile
detention center.
I am not a ghost.
This is completely made up.
But things from my real
life do end up in my books.
And so the ballet stuff
is from real life.
I studied ballet from when
I was 4 to when I was 16.
I was not very good.
I never would have been a
professional like Violet
in this story.
But it was just so
much a part of my life
going to ballet class after
school, going on the weekends,
doing performances like this.
And the last performance that I
did before I quit ballet to go
hang out with my friends and go
to parties, which is the truth.
That's what happened, the last
ballet that I performed in
was "The Firebird,"
and I was one
of the dancing maidens, which
is the role that Violet actually
does get.
And I remember I had a very
plain costume in comparison
to the firebird's
costume, and we
had little bean
bags, gold bean bags
that we had to throw on stage.
And this was the
greatest fear of mine,
that I would not catch it when
it came to me, because I'm
terrible at catching things.
So it was just this
very vivid memory.
But I remembered you
know the dancer who
danced "The Firebird," and that
incredibly intense dancing,
the incredibly intense solo.
It was such a memorable
point in my life.
And she was trapped.
This character's trapped.
And just that feeling felt
very connected to "The Walls
Around Us."
And also, at least the dancer
who was in the performance
that I was in, there was this
anger that was all through her.
And it just really
felt connected
to when I wanted
to write this book.
So when I knew Violet was going
to be a ballerina, of course,
it had to be "The Firebird."
It had to be with the
ballet that I remembered,
the last one that I danced in,
but also, the story felt right.
AUDIENCE: And if Amber, or
Violet, and Ori were boys,
how do you think your
story would be different?
NOVA REN SUMA: That is such
an interesting question.
It's funny.
I most exclusively write about
teenage girls and about girls.
And I can't even imagine
what it would be like
for me to write this
story about three boys
in a juvenile detention center.
And I think maybe--
clearly, that's a story
that I would love to read.
That's a story
that another writer
would be able to make
so vivid and wonderful.
But for me, so
much of my writing
is about writing about
the experience of being
a teenage girl and all kinds of
girls, exploring all avenues.
And so I can't even
fathom how that book
would be if written by me.
So I'm intrigued
by the question,
but I don't even know.
I feel like it would
be not a book by me.
It would be another
worthy book, but not
something that I would
be able to do justice.
AUDIENCE: Well, and
also, knowing the prison
dynamics would be very
different, and also,
[INAUDIBLE] competitive
dance world.
NOVA REN SUMA: Yes.
The ballet stuff
would be different.
And there's something
really interesting
to explore with female
friendship, and enemies,
and friends, and how that
can be the same thing.
That can be the same person.
And friendship with guys
is probably different,
but there's something really
interesting with girls.
And there's the girls
in the prison, locked up
in the prison, and there's
the girls in the dance school.
And the girls in the dance
school are just as vicious
and mean as the
girls in the prison.
AUDIENCE: That's a
"Black Swan" reference.
NOVA REN SUMA: [LAUGHING] Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And so here's
a metaphysical question.
What are your thoughts on karma,
regret, and how supernatural
[? would get involved? ?]
NOVA REN SUMA: I find
that a lot of times
when I'm writing these
fantastical stories, there
always is some kind
of karmic retribution.
Like if somebody does something
magical or has a power,
there's always some
consequence for that.
In the worlds that I create,
I can't imagine there not
being some
consequence, something
that you do that you're
not allowed to do,
that then you have to pay for.
So I think that
kind of philosophy
has seeped its
way into my books,
and so when I imagine
something completely fantastic,
and strange, and
in another world,
I'm thinking of that rule.
And that's come
through in my book,
"Imaginary Girls," and I think
here in "The Walls Around Us,"
there's that feeling
of who deserves what,
and what happens when
someone who doesn't deserve
it starts getting a lot, getting
all the good things happening
to her, is that really
going to come through?
And in real life, we
know that a lot of times
there's no retribution,
and terrible people
get wonderful things.
But maybe in
fiction, I have a way
of correcting that a little bit.
AUDIENCE: To cosmic justice.
And so I think a number of
us are a little more extreme
in saying we're curious to
hear more about this launch pad
workshop that you attended.
It's not often that
you hear about writers
going to a workshop
that's funded by NASA--
NOVA REN SUMA: Right.
AUDIENCE: --astronomy.
What was your experience
like from that,
and what did you
take away from it?
And how has it
influenced your work?
NOVA REN SUMA: Well, I should
say that the Launch Pad
Astronomy Workshop is at
the University of Wyoming
every summer.
And it's open to writers who
are interested in bringing
in some science into their
writing, specifically
astronomy.
So you don't have to be
a science fiction writer.
You don't have to
be a science writer.
I'm a YA writer who
writes magical things.
But I had a book in
mind that's still
in progress about an astronaut,
and I needed more basis
to make sure I wasn't
making terrible mistakes,
but also, inspiration.
And so I was really
excited to apply and get
the funding to go.
And every year, I think it's
funded from different places.
So the year I went,
it was funded by NASA.
I don't know who's funding
it for the next summer.
So I went.
And really, what it is is
an intense, week long class
on astronomy, like intense, like
hours of learning astronomy.
And if you've taken an
astronomy college course before,
some of it might be
an old hat to you.
For me, it was all new.
I hadn't taken
astronomy in college,
and so I had a lot to learn.
But at the same time,
we moved past the basics
and into a lot of what ifs
with terraforming Mars,
or all these really
interesting ideas.
And I learned so much.
I filled up notebooks
full of notes.
Also, you're with a
group of a fellow writers
from different genres-- science
fiction and fantasy writers,
and there were some YA writers,
and just short story writers.
And we really bonded and
connected while we were there.
And there were also some
visits to a telescope
to see the stars, and so it was
a really, really interesting
week.
And if that anyone
is listening to this
and thinks that's
interesting, there
should be another
one next summer.
And I think the applications
open in the winter.
AUDIENCE: And we'll open it up
to questions from the audience.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
I was going to say--
so she said that [INAUDIBLE]
got a chance [? to read it. ?]
I just picked it up.
NOVA REN SUMA: Oh, thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: She said
about how you write so well.
You develop the other characters
in the prison and everything
so well.
If you could, is there
anybody in particular
that you [INAUDIBLE]
side [INAUDIBLE]
that you would really love to go
on a tangent with, if you have?
NOVA REN SUMA: Well, you
know what's interesting
about this book is there's
this main, central figure
in this book called
Ori Orianna who doesn't
get her own perspective.
And her story is told through
the eyes of Amber, who's
her cell mate, and then
through the eyes of Violet,
who was her former best friend.
And so you piece together
this portrait of her
through other people's
eyes, which I always find
so fascinating, as a reader.
I love that kind of
stuff in the story.
But then it leaves why
did I not tell the story
from Ori's prospective?
A lot of readers
have asked me, why
is there not Ori's perspective?
And there was one
point where I was like,
should I have letters from her?
Should I add some of
that in the story?
I even think I tried, and
I couldn't find her voice.
So I think I would try a more
secondary character, someone
that nobody would expect.
There's a girl who is an
outcast and eats her own hair.
Her name is Kennedy.
She might be
interesting to explore.
There's a girl who's
surreptitiously dealing drugs.
Her name is Peaches.
She might be
interesting to explore.
I feel like anyone of them
might lead to something,
but it would be a
whole separate story.
It would be her story, and then
it would touch the other one.
But it's interesting.
There's a lot of
vivid possibility,
if I ever wanted to write
something beyond this.
But then again, my stories
are always standalone.
They're meant to be
just what they are.
Even if they leave
questions at the end,
the reader is left to
ask those questions
and determine the
answers on their own.
Thank you for the question.
It looks like we're
up [? time. ?]
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Thank you so much for coming in.
[INAUDIBLE]
Please take up a copy of her
book, "The Walls Around Us."
It's in the back of the room.
But thank you.
NOVA REN SUMA: Thank you.
Thank you so much everyone
for the [INAUDIBLE].
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]